[Musique]
relâche au parlement en raison des
élections législatives qui auront lieu
au mois de juin et donc je vais profiter
de ces semaines devant nous pour aller à
la rencontre de tous les élus de la
vienne des responsables associatifs des
responsables économiques pour connaître
leurs projets leurs préoccupations leurs
difficultés
un tour de la vienne en 86 jours c'est
ce qu'on vous propose avec mary deros
sénatrice suppléante voilà voyage au
centre de nos terres voyage au centre de
nos territoires pour venir à votre
rencontre j'accompagne à la rencontre
des maires et adjoints des
[Musique]
alors ces rencontres vont être aussi
l'occasion pour moi de faire le point
sur eux on travaille au sénat au sein de
la délégation aux droits des femmes au
sein de la commission de l'aménagement
du territoire sur des textes importants
pour les élus comme l'alouette iii dsk
était entérinée ou bien encore sur eux
des propositions que l'on a fait ou tout
récemment sur l'accès territoriales aux
soins ou encore sur eux le maintien du
commerce en milieu rural une vraie
préoccupation pour les élus comme ici à
marcoussis ici entre l'aréna inventé par
dino belin et le futuroscope créé par
année
symbole de l'attractivité de notre
département
non
de partage des changes et de travail
pour l'avenir
mon commune et de notre ruralité
voilà vous rencontrez c'est aussi pour
pouvoir faire remonter vos
préoccupations
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire
régulièrement au président du sénat que
vous soyez entendu ici pour que sur le
terrain évidemment vos projets
aboutissent et que la vienne continue
évidemment aller bien
[Musique]